what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and we also talk sp umc
sony pictures of marvel characters i'm
actually i don't think they call it that
anymore i think they came up with a new
name but they've switched the name so
many times already that i just
don't care to keep up anymore we all
know what it is but that's a perfect
example of what i believe is sony's lack
of a plan i don't think they really know
what direction they want to go with
right now in terms of their spider-man
universe which is really what this video
is about i think that sony has very
recently made a pretty big spider-man
mistake now this mistake could be easily
fix so there is hope here but basically
what i think sony's very huge mistake is
is that they think people just flat out
love spider-man no matter what and yes
we love spider-man we want more of
spider-man but here's the deal just
because spider-man's in a movie or a
show or a project doesn't mean we're
just automatically going to love that
movie show or project it has to be
good but this is where sony's mistake
comes in where they just think that we
just want spider-man and it'll be okay
but i'm going to tell you what i think
sony's thought process is in regards to
spider-man and their spider-man universe
and how i think they could actually fix
it and how i think there could be some
hope and of course if you love marvel
and want to stay up to date on all
things marvel be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
videos now a couple things you need to
know one is that i love marvel uh all
the shows that are coming up craven the
hunter madame webb the spider woman
movie i have hope for all of these films
i really wanted to like morbius
unfortunately i didn't but i really
wanted to and
it's not as terrible as people say but
it's not good more on that in just a bit
but before i start with sony's big
spiderman mistake there is something
that you need to know that has recently
come out and that is the director of
morbius daniel espinoza went on twitter
to do and ask me anything where people
asked if a spider-man does exist in the
venom slash morbius universe which he
confirmed they are the same universe and
his answer was yes if spider-man does
exist in that universe he actually said
of course in which they asked well
which spider-man exists in this universe
and and he said that it is his
understanding that it'll be revealed
soon this is important to know because
it's clear sony has plans to introduce
their own spider-man in their own
universe separate from the mcu now
morbius
wasn't good it's not as terrible as some
people are saying it out there but it's
not good and the reason is is because
it's so chopped up it seems like they
really edited a lot of it now i've been
saying this for a few videos now it was
filmed over three years ago it had about
two years of delays and a lot of things
have happened in the meantime but
unfortunately this led to sony making a
mistake sony saw spider-man no way home
as a very very big opportunity they saw
fans going crazy over spider-man no way
home going crazy about seeing toby
maguire and angie garfield and yes we
loved it we love seeing the other two
generations of spider-man join tom
holland all on one big screen it was
fantastic to see toby and andrew and tom
holland together but it was a fantastic
movie the movie was amazing and kevin
feige was in charge but here's what sony
did they went wow everybody loves
spider-man everybody loves toby and
andrew and tom holland and they went
well we can't fully have tom holland
spider-man in our universe because he's
in the mcu but
we can have andrew garfield spider-man
and we can have toby maguire spider-man
cameo in some projects as well so we can
make andrew garfield or another new
spider-man if they want to do that the
main spider-man of our universe and have
it completely separate from the mcu and
do our own thing people love spider-man
but that doesn't mean anything
spider-man touches is going to be good
just ask fans what they think about
spider-man 3 which i actually do happen
to like despite the general opinion of
the fans but also ask them what they
think about tasm 1 or tasm 2. now these
movies have grown their fan base and
they've earned their respect over time
of course and they're not by any means
terrible movies but they did get a lot
of backlash at first and it took a while
for them to gain that fan base i mean
there's a reason it was rebooted a third
time so the point is that just because
it's a spider-man project doesn't mean
that it's going to be good in all
honesty i actually thought sony had a
plan the first time i watched morbius
and i saw the post-credits scene i
thought sony might have a plan here
especially with the venom let to be
carnage post-credits scene as well but
now i'm starting to think that they
probably don't at this point in time my
thought process was sony changed morbius
a lot and cut it up because spiderman no
way home came out and changed their
plans for the spiderman universe so they
cut scenes related to spider-man and the
mcu out of their movie and if you think
about it it makes sense there was the
picture of spider-man that said murderer
over it and this was most likely
referring to mysterio they had vulture
in the actual movie originally and then
they took him out then they did the
post-credits scene to try and explain
what was actually happening with
spider-man and at first i thought okay
this is very sloppily executed but i see
what they're getting at i see the plan
in the works but now i'm not so sure i
think their plan was simply let's have
our own spider-man and do a sinister six
film eventually i don't think this is
much of a plan unfortunately and i think
it's shown by the first post-credit of
morbius that just makes zero sense like
it just makes zero sense they went well
we need this character in our universe
so let's just use doctor strange's spell
and bring him into this universe all of
a sudden because he's connected to
spider-man and if you haven't seen the
post credit i'm avoiding saying any type
of names or anything like that but then
it gets even more confusing in the
second post credit scene where you have
this character now in the universe
interacting with morbius saying hey
let's be good guys i don't what do you
mean let's be good guys and then all of
a sudden he says you know let's go after
spider-man well what did spider-man do
in this universe
right who is the spider-man in this
universe because in the old universe you
were defending spider-man you wouldn't
even give up peter parker's true
identity you were helping him in a way
at the end you didn't hate him and now
all of a sudden it's like hey let's go
after spider-man
doesn't really make sense and morbius
didn't really offer us any explanation
of what this universal spider-man could
be like and again i think it's because
sony really doesn't have any idea right
now unfortunately and to top it all off
sony teased the heck out of us with the
venom let there be carnage post credit
scene putting eddie brock tom hardy's
eddie brock and venom in the mcu only
two kind of immediately in the post
credits for spider-man noway home bring
him back to the sony universe again they
seemingly just don't know which
direction they want to go in their own
spider-man universe i think this is a
really big mistake on sony's part just
simply going with the fact that people
love spider-man however there is some
hope they do have a lot of cool projects
coming up like madame webb craven the
hunter a spider-woman movie another
venom movie as well they do have a good
foundation to be able to build an entire
spider-man universe off of if you wanted
to include like andrew garfield
spider-man because i don't think
introducing a brand new spider-man would
be good i think that it could work and
there is hope however i do believe that
they should at least consult with marvel
studios now they already do consult with
kevin feige and marvel studios but
they've shown in the past that they
don't always take the advice given to
them i think they need to take the
advice of kevin feige clearly he knows
how to run a connected cinematic
universe he's been doing this for over
10 years and he knows how to do it
better than anybody so if sony wants to
kind of bend their ear to kevin feige
and actually take the advice that he
gives them i think we could actually
have a pretty decent spider-man universe
over at sony especially if it is indeed
andrew garfield spider-man but they have
to listen to marvel studios at least a
little bit and not ignore advice from
the man kevin feige now sony doesn't
really seem to have a plan right now but
it looks like they are trying to come up
with somewhat of a plan they did tease
the sinister six and that morbius post
credit scene so hopefully that actually
builds up and doesn't just happen like
in the next movie they need to introduce
the spider-man in the universe have a
few films with them in it have a few
films with the villains in it and make
them true villains not like hey let's do
some good but hey let's also get
spider-man no make them true villains
make morbius a true villain i think
he'll be a lot better that way vulture
craven the hunter and anybody else they
want to bring in venom etc make them
true villains and make them go after
spider-man after a few movies of
introducing everybody we could have a
pretty killer movie there but let me
know what you think about all of this in
the comments down below do you think
there's hope for the spider-man universe
over at sony let me know your thoughts
in the comments down below don't forget
to like the video and subscribe you
don't miss out on any of the latest
marvel news for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you